Hi, I'm just wondering, you know, I'm, I'm, thank you for answering my, because I, I
want to travel to Cuba too. Cuba, Cuba, it's okay to take my machine too.
You know, I, I can't answer that definitively because I've never been to Cuba. I've never
tried to take it into there. You're always dealing whatever you take at your machine into
another country. You're dealing with a human who's making a decision. Yeah, that's the difficult.
You get somebody who didn't eat lunch today and they could be a little hankerous. So it's,
there is that risk factor. We used to do, you know, we used to live in Mexico. We used to do a lot of
work and bringing this stuff across the border in Mexico, doing missionary work. And it was
always an issue where they were trying to get us to bribe them. And, and I, and I felt for them
because they probably got paid almost nothing to do their job and knowing that they're going to make
money on bribe. But as the poor missionary, we didn't have anybody to give anybody money for bribes.
I just played stupid all the time to the point where they got so disgusted with me that they let
me go. Bye. So, um, my, my, my, my, my fear and idea that is that if they think they could make
money off of a sheet that you really did, and they think there's value that they could resell it,
I'd hate to have them confiscated. In this case, what, what's the solution? Because basically,
I want to, you know, I'm from Europe and I'm traveling, you know, I don't, I don't know. And I just,
I want to use my machine. I want to heal, you know, this. So, how long are you going to be
on this trip? I'm planning to go to Cuba at least two weeks, but, but sometimes I'm going to Europe for
month. Well, I don't think you're going to trouble at Europe. We've not had any issues with Europe.
We've had numerous patients from European countries bring their machine back with them, no problem.
So, so the computer put it into the carry-on and the machine can be put into the bigger.
Sure. You could put the machine in your carry-on, the computer, the carry-on, you could put the
involvement in your, in your, in your check luggage. And I don't think you're going to even get questioned.
But, uh, but going into Cuba, I think that way, that could be an issue. So, I just don't know how
stricter lacks they are with, with whatever you bring into that country. So, I've not had anybody go
there before. Oh, really? Because I'm going to get some, some sunshine, you know, I'm living in Henley.
Why don't you, you know, see? Can I go with you? Yes, please, please, bring your rifle machine.
Okay, heal. And, you know, we can, I really, really.